oh excuse me um kind sir what time is it
order time question can you do a live
ask IJ song right now everybody's got a
question sing it ask anything
Wow so many things that happens in the
last episode of ask IJ I got into a
fight with a Sprint employee the new
iPhone is out
I saved the whales and I hit a hundred
thousand subscribers on YouTube and what
if I always talked like that I took a
question today he's from one I just seen
fan and they asked Justine are you gonna
get the new iPhone
are you serious of course I'm gonna get
the new iPhone first if you want to know
more about the new iPhone check my blog
iJustine comm we've got a little
write-up so you can see all the new
treats there's video copy and paste and
that's really all that matters to me
alright be got a youtube comment here
that says Justine I hate you I hope that
you burn in who picked this question why
would you guys give me a question that
someone asks me if they hate who did
this I'm gonna fight no you're fired all
right it's time for the YouTube video
question
this how do you do that what program I
use Tanner actually cheated and asked me
three questions but I'm answering this
question because everyone seems to ask
me how I get those images on my sidebar
it's actually pretty simple I'll try to
take it step by step for you guys first
I shoot and edit a rough cut of my video
in iMovie using my eyesight I export the
video in full quality and then I import
that file into Final Cut Pro I continue
to edit this file in Final Cut Pro
adding music adding graphics and any
other fun stuff that I might want to add
then when I'm finally done with those
edits I create a separate sequence that
is an HD now you drag your edited
sequence file into the HD sequence and
you'll notice you'll get those black
bars and we don't want those bring
yourself a spiffy little image in
Photoshop import it into Final Cut and
drag that image right below your edited
file while laughs black bars are gone
thanks for watching don't forget follow
me on Twitter ask me questions using the
ask edgy hashtag leave comments below
for more questions and uh yeah that's it
see you guys next time oh yeah you can
leave video responses too
create yourself a spiffy little spittle
rescreen